hurry for the wait yea Mizuki
Hey hello you still in work I am we are
officially on the same continent you
okay
just wondering why you're not on the
plane right now is your flight delayed
it was canceled I know but I'm
definitely still coming I'm like halfway
there now I'll see you know might as
well that is fine it's just a bit of
snow but I'm flying in the morning and
then we can all go out for dinner
I'll pay Oh like you tell my parents
that in person you know it's not my
fault this time
I know I just don't think they'll care
whose fault it is cuz you're still not
here
I should go okay I love you I love you
too
what the hell I am so sorry
sorry get the fuck out of here yes sorry
what did I just say I know I know I'm so
sorry but there has been some sort of
mistake
this is my room what is this some kind
of British humor
coz I'm sorry but I don't understand
what get out
you gotta have something how about a
sweet I could pay well then put him in
someone else's room fat I'll be down in
a minute you called me a cab
are you serious it's just no damn it
bill
alright come on they're British hey
chocolate what time's your flight
tomorrow what the hell you doing boy I
said first this is my bed I know this
isn't ideal but we could top and tail if
you like what no you don't understand I
eat something yesterday it ain't
agreeing with me I'm gonna be in and out
of this bed all night sweating like a
hawk you do not want to sleep with me
you want some ipecac what the hell's
that well basically it makes you vomit
but it will get rid of whatever's in
your system you doctor oh no I'm
actually training to be a nurse Shh
yeah convenient for you isn't it no just
that I ain't never met a male nurse
before well there are plenty others in
the UK at least yeah
yeah what it's kind of gay listen are
you actually ill what you just not feel
comfortable sharing a bed with another
man cuz it makes you feel any better I
don't want to have sex with you tonight
you call me a fag Wow
get the fuck off of my bed
listen it's my first time here so I
guess I just didn't realize the people
this intolerant actually existed so you
listen to me pretty boy hello he thinks
I'm pretty whatever you do in the
privacy of your own home that's between
you and the Lord
but this here this is my house that's a
harsh night out and I'm offering you my
hospitality but this is my bed and that
is yours if you so much as think bunking
up with me I'll pound you not in the way
you'd like me to understand
hello I'm just wondering if you have any
extra beds that you can maybe set up to
the no okay maybe a sleeping bag no okay
now that's just fine no worries good
night
Oh God I knew you were a faggot what did
you do to me
sorry I couldn't sleep yes you could
owed me
don't touch me let me help you you'll be
okay but you should probably eat
something I've got some painkillers if
you want mine all right
hi are you okay I just have already
slept what time is it oh yeah it's just
bit of a rough night but I'm fine what
is it oh it's okay I'm sorry if I come
on this trip sooner then you won't even
have anything to be pissed at me about
Thanks
but I love you too
by
have a good flight
whatever
you